que ce sont les candidats qui
choisissent le duo de journalisme est ce
qu'on a peur alors que les combats ne
choisissent pas si elena mais j'en suis
le premier témoin ils viennent a failli
se bat pour venir dans cette émission
est donc pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
n'accepteraient pas que l'animateur de
l'émission à laquelle ils veulent
systématiquement venir à nîmes ce second
tour
par ailleurs il ya un certain nombre de
candidats qui à l'animation de cette de
ce second tour qui ont été rejetées
c'est le cas de crespo mora de
delahousse de julian bugier certains
étaient jugés trop anti le pen d'autres
pros macron d'autres aux jeunes
d'ailleurs donc les candidats ils ont
leur mot à dire dans ce choix est donc
peut-être qu'on devrait leur laisser
dire ce que veulent voir animer puis il
ya un dernier point c'est que on
pourrait peut-être vous demander votre
avis parce que aujourd'hui votre masque
à vous la marque hanouna elle vaut plus
que celle de n'importe quel autre
personnalité politique est donc le
premier qui pourrait avoir une image
écornée en animant ce débat c'est vous
exactement leur genre parlait justement
dans un instant je vais donner à mon
avis aussi là dessus
juste avant je voudrais qu'on écoute
pierre henri dumont députée les
républicains du pas de calais pour vous
c'est n'importe quoi c'est n'importe
quoi parce que ces deux métiers
différents vous faites du divertissement
on pouvait faire de l'infotainment mais
vous faites pas vous n'êtes pas
spécialiste de la vie politique quand on
a mené un débat qui est celui le plus
crucial de la vie politique française
c'est le débat d'entre deux tours on se
souvient du débat entre giscard et
mitterrand l'aller et le retour qui a
fait basculer l'élection en 74 en
particulier quand on se souvient du
crash qui était celui de marine le pen
tendance ouvert aussi débat hollande de
sarkozy avec ça fait basculer les
élections et donc s'il y a en face de
vous un candidat qui sort une fake news
à mensonge et que vous n'êtes pas assez
préparés sur un sujet où assez calé sur
le sujet malheureusement sera pas
possible de le démasquer assez lisse un
script elle l'a trouvée préparer elle a
elle-même reconnu à la sortie de
l'émission qu'elle se sentait comme un
poireau c'est dire l'intérêt
et au fond la qualité de son rôle dans
ce débat est là et même peut-être
peut-être mais je pense vraiment qu'il y
a deux métiers et que si vous pensiez
pas non mais celui-ci bien que c'est pas
de vidéo qui devrait y avoir un bassiste
vraiment voilà et à côté un meilleur des
cas durant la campagne des candidats
viennent ici que vous ayez eu à des pris
la décision d'interviewer l'ensemble des
différents comment un par un pour
creuser pour toucher une population
jeune
bien sûr c'est aussi votre rôle mais à
côté animal d'animer le débat du second
tour qui est juste le moment le plus
crucial de cette élection présidentielle
je pense qu'il faut est bon c'est vrai
mais bon ça il faut avoir au futur c'est
compliqué parce qu'ils aimaient non mais
il ya deux semaines de seconde tout à
fait quatorze jours les américains ils
font pas car cela entre les médias qu'un
seul tour ouais ya qu un seul tour
chacun 50 de candidates rupture et moi
c'est qu'ils sont sur trois mois ce qui
me choque aussi c'est ton donné par les
cds c'est ça qui est mais voilà lorsque
ses contres marlène schiappa parce
qu'ils veulent taper sur le gouvernement
sera que c'est ça aussi qui fait que
voilà tout le monde l'a repris derrière
on va pas dire oui parce que vous
bousculer le paysage
non ici là bas nos et quand vous voyez
les extraits vous voyez que les
présentateurs sont presque pas de raison
que symboliseraient nice 10 waouh
pourquoi parce que quand même
globalement monsieur le député vous
faites je trouve de la vieille politique
les présentateurs aujourd'hui comme
certains politiques qui parlent pas de
vie quotidienne vous savez très bien
beaucoup de journalistes politiques je
parle pas pour christophe mais sont
déconnectés de la vie des gens et cyril
hanouna il va remettre le débat dans la
connexion avec les vraies préoccupations
des gens il va leur parler à eux tous
et quand vous dites non j'ai
l'impression aussi monsieur
respectueusement que vous aussi vous
avez peur de sa peur dans les vraies
préoccupations désormais que cyril
viguier
pardon mais j'ai pas besoin d'aller sur
un plateau télé pour entendre les
préoccupations des gens enfin vous savez
je suis dans une ville dense mille
habitants dont j'étais maire j'ai été
élu très jeune à 26 ans dans ma commune
j'ai été élu et réélu parce que les gens
m'ont fait confiance et j'essaie de
résoudre leur problème et qu'elle m'en
donnez moi la crise et gilet jaune le
premier jour j'étais sur les ronds
points avec les gens pour les écouter
pour savoir ce que sur le plateau de
syrie
et j les 27 premiers plateaux qui je
pense qu'il faut faire attention aux
caricatures vraiment sûr sera là